Speaker 1: The IRS must hand over Donald
Trump's taxes, says a judge at this point.
This is more of a ha ha thing than substantively
meaningful. If and until Donald Trump declares
that he is again a candidate for the Republican
nomination in 2024. But this is something that's
been going on for so long. Think back to the
primary period in 2016 when Donald Trump was
asked people with tears in their eyes saying,
Sir, where are your taxes? And Donald Trump said,
I'm under audit. Once there's no more audit, I
will release my tax returns. And of course, it
never made sense. Why didn't it make sense? Well,
he obviously wasn't under audit for every year.
Why didn't he release the taxes for the years? Not
under audit. Because it was all a lie all along.
And a House committee investigating malfeasance
and wrongdoing and subterfuge has been trying to
obtain Donald Trump's taxes for years at this
point. This is supposedly the absolute final,
definitive last step. Rolling Stone reporting
IRS must hand Trump's tax returns over to the
House committee, according to a court Judge David
Sentell wrote Tuesday, the chairman has identified
a legitimate legislative purpose that it requires
information to accomplish. Oh, I don't have this
article here. I guess I have to subscribe
to Rolling Stone. But I can tell you what
the determination is. One of the things that's at
issue when a judge is to determine a question like
does the IRS have to give tax returns to a House
committee? Is is there a valid, legitimate,
substantive reason legislatively for the House
committee to have these taxes? If a court believes
or determines that the reason that the House wants
Trump or anyone else's tax returns from the IRS
is out of curiosity. A fishing expedition to
make someone look bad, or for any other reason
other than a legislatively substantive reason.
They would say the IRS does not have to turn
these documents over. What the court found is that
there is legitimate and substantive justification
for the House of Representatives committee to have
those tax returns. So Trump is having a really,
really bad week. I don't know at this point
what would come from a public standpoint, from
Donald Trump's taxes being given to this House
committee. But consider that if he does run again,
he is, of course, going to try to shield his taxes
again. I mean, listen, the guy won without ever
publishing his taxes, which is something no other
presidential candidate has been able to do. And so
I'm still interested in seeing what's there.
I think that all of the things we expected
would be there. Trump's not as wealthy as he
claims to be. Trump plays very fast and loose
with the values of many of his assets, all of
these different things, and what impact they would
have on Trump voters at this. Point is probably
almost zero. But what a week of photos surfaced
showing Trump flushing documents down toilets.
Mar a Lago is raided. He has to be deposed by
Letitia James and now his taxes are going to the
House committee. Not a particularly good week